we're going to begin with this because
just hours after launching his
re-election campaign President Biden is
already hammering home his pitch for a
second term president made it very clear
he's keeping vice president Kamala
Harris as his running mate and both of
them gave major speeches yesterday
warning against right-wing extremism now
if the current polling holes the
president could be headed for a rematch
against Donald Trump though it's still
very early to call that Nancy Cordes is
at the White House with more Nancy good
morning to you good morning to you Gail
the first Biden campaign ads start
airing today they're not wasting any
time the party is quickly closing ranks
behind the Biden Harris ticket with
hopes that a key endorsement will help
boost enthusiasm about a second term
over here
speaking before a supportive Union crowd
blocks from the White House Tuesday
President Biden made the case for
another four years we're in the cusp of
major change we're creating jobs again
manufacturing has come alive again early
campaign teams already emerging abortion
rights lgbtq rights and access to the
voting booth so many of our hard-won
freedoms are under attack and this is a
moment for us to stand and fight Vermont
Senator and one-time Democratic
presidential rival Bernie Sanders was
quick to endorse the Biden ticket
yesterday saying the quote last thing
the country needs is a Donald Trump or
some other right-wing demagogue to
undermine American democracy it feels
like the train is coming off the tracks
the Republican National Committee
reacted to the re-election bid by
releasing this AI generated video
predicting a dystopian second Biden term
according to a CBS news poll 72 percent
of Americans feel things in the U.S are
out of control the Republican
front-runner quickly weighed in too with
such a calamitous and failed presidency
it is almost inconceivable that Biden
would even think of running for
re-election nearly half of all Democrats
say they don't think Mr Biden should run
again most of them citing his age he
would be 86 at the end of a second term
Mr President
um plan to serve all eight years
I'm not I'm just not going to get ahead
of the president that's something for
him to decide White House Press
Secretary Kareem Jean-Pierre later
clarified those comments tweeting I can
confirm that if re-elected the president
would serve all eight years
one of the benefits of running for the
White House from the White House is the
many opportunities to appear
presidential today Mr Biden is hosting
the South Korean president a key Ally as
tensions rise with China there's going
to be a rare State dinner here tonight
meanwhile another Republican hopeful is
making it official today former Arkansas
governor ASA Hutchinson is formally
announcing his presidential bid he's one
of the few GOP candidates who has been
willing to openly criticize Donald Trump
Nate
Nancy thank you